this video is brought to you by pimsler
maker of the world famous pimsler audio
language courses which I've used for
several languages use my link in the
description for a free 7-Day trial of
their online subscription plan the Dutch
language is the third most widely spoken
Germanic language after English and
German it's the official language of the
Netherlands and one of the official
languages of Belgium where it's the
native language of around 60% of the
population mainly in the northern region
of Flanders no not this Flanders this
Flanders in Dutch flandre the history of
the Netherlands and Belgium are closely
linked and they were under the same rule
at several points in their history
including the United Kingdom of the
Netherlands from 1815 to 1830 but then
the Belgian Revolution resulted in the
creation of the kingdom of Belgium at
first it had only one official language
French even though a large percentage of
its population was Flemish in Dutch
flams but Dutch eventually became an
official language alongside French in
Belgium and the only official language
in the region of Flanders except for the
Brussels Capital Region which is
bilingual That official language is
standard Dutch but Belgian standard
Dutch which has some slight differences
from the standard Dutch used in the
Netherlands including some differences
in vocabulary but it's standard Dutch
but as in the Netherlands numerous
spoken dialects are used in Flanders
which can differ widely from Stander
Dutch and from each other these dialects
are collectively referred to as Flemish
or flams Flemish speakers often speak
these dialects with family friends and
other people who speak the same or a
similar dialect but it's the 21st
century and there are lots of people who
don't stay in the same town forever they
move to other parts of the country and
talk to speakers of other dialects you
might assume that Flemish people speak
standard Dutch in these situations but
that's not exactly the case a variety of
Flemish has emerged called tental which
literally means between language or
inter language it's a semi-standardized
INF formal way of speaking that includes
some elements of standard Dutch and some
elements of dialect especially bonian
dialects while older Generations grew up
speaking their local dialect as their
main spoken language these days many
people use tental as their main spoken
language tental is also the main form of
spoken Flemish used in television shows
and the like except in formal broadcasts
like the news which use Belgian standard
Dutch but tental is not spoken exactly
the same everywhere and by everyone it
differs a little bit depending on the
person and locality in the Netherlands
many dialects are still spoken too but
standard Dutch has been continuously
growing as a spoken language of daily
use and is often used in situations when
tental would be used in Belgium so let's
compare the way Dutch people generally
speak standard Dutch in their everyday
lives with the way Flemish people speak
tental in their everyday lives
pronunciation there are some differences
in pronunciation between Dutch Dutch and
Flemish though it's important to note
that dialects in the southern part of
the Netherlands are often similar to
Flemish dialects spoken in Flanders one
major difference is the pronunciation of
the sound represented by G and CH in the
Netherlands it's the so-called hard G
this is a voiceless uvular fricative in
Flanders it's the so-called soft G
either a voiced or voiceless Veer
frickative or which doesn't sound as
guttural as the hard G and the letter
combination CH always indicates the
voiceless h regardless of position the
word for good in
Netherlands and in
Flanders the word for glass in
Flanders the word for laugh in
Netherlands and in
Flanders the word for school in
Netherlands SCH and in Flanders schol
the word for day in
Netherlands and in
Flanders another difference final T
sounds are often dropped in Flemish like
instead of meaning not instead of
meaning that instead of what meaning
what Etc I don't know in
Netherlands and in
Flanders notice the final T that is
dropped this also happens with h sounds
H and the pronoun is often shortened to
C here's another sentence meaning that
doesn't work literally that goes not in
Netherlands and in
Flanders notice that the final T of each
word can be dropped in Flemish
speech when words like DS and buts
introduce a subordinate clause they can
contract with the subject pronoun that
follows
especially
D people always think that I'm German in
the
Netherlands
and
grammar we'll look at some differences
in grammar in a minute but first I'd
like to talk about an amazing way to
learn Dutch or any of 50 other languages
I'm talking about the legendary pimsler
method pimsler courses consist of 30
minute daily audio lessons that teach
you the building blocks of a language
and how to use them confidently since
these are audio courses they're
excellent for learning good
pronunciation and they help you avoid
the Trap of only studying with a
textbook and focusing on reading and
grammar pimsler courses are great but
their CD courses used to be really
expensive but they've solved that
problem with their new online
subscription service you can gain access
to all the lessons in one language for
$1 199.95 per month or all 51 languages
for just $1 more these online lessons
include not just the core audio lessons
that pimsler is famous for they also
include new reading lessons and review
tools like flashcards if you do one 30
minute lesson per day as intended then
completing a course is much cheaper than
if you buy one of pimsler standalone
courses and the all access option with
51 languages is an amazing value for
people who want to practice multiple
languages use my link in the description
to try it risk-free people in these
countries get a 7-Day free trial and can
join all access on the website or
smartphone app people in other countries
get a free trial lesson to join all
access they need to use the smartphone
app rather than the website there's some
weird legal reason for that but anyway
the subscription is worth the effort if
you sign up for a free trial or a
subscription Lang Focus gets a small
referral fee that helps support this
channel so it's win-win it's great for
you and it's good for Lang Focus too
just make sure to use the link in the
description or pinned comment and now
let's get back to grammar another
standout feature of Flemish speech is
the use of the singular U
pronoun rather
than and in Flemish speech you'll hear
the second person singular pronoun in
standard Dutch this is a formal subject
and object pronoun while in Flemish it's
informal but is used mainly as an object
pronoun not as a subject pronoun this
pronoun is still used in the Netherlands
but sounds very formal there's also a
slight difference in conjugation between
Y and in standard Dutch the final T of
the second singular present tense
conjugation is dropped when the pronoun
comes after it in a question for example
in standard Dutch you speak Dutch is you
Netherlands and as a question your
Netherland do you speak Dutch but in
Flemish the T isn't dropped
Netherlands
Netherlands also for the second person
plural in standard Dutch the standard
plural conjugation is used while in
Flemish the singular conjugation is used
you speak Dutch
well another difference in subject
pronouns is that in Flemish they're
often doubled I'm going in the
Netherlands and in fland
I think that I'm
going and it
Flanders the pronoun I doesn't have an
unstressed form but with other pronouns
it's usually an unstressed form plus the
stressed form she's staying here in
Netherlands and in
Flanders sometimes pronouns can even be
repeated three times this sentence means
I don't speak Dutch or I don't speak any
Dutch in the Netherlands
it's
and in Flanders
it's first the verb in this sentence is
which in standard Dutch means to clap or
to fold but in Flanders it can be used
with the meaning of speak second notice
that the first person singular pronoun
appears in this sentence three
times gender historically in Dutch there
were three genders masculine feminine
and neuter in the Netherlands for the
most part nouns no longer have a
distinction between masculine and
feminine gender they've merged so now
there are just two classes of nouns
common gender and neuter there's just
one singular indefinite article for all
nouns for
example in southern Dutch and Flemish
though there are still three genders the
indefinite article for singular
masculine nouns is while for feminine
its and for
neuter
yes another difference in grammar is
that Flemish dialects and tental often
have an extra dot after another word
that introduces a subordinate clause we
don't know where he lives in the
Netherlands word for word it's we know
not where he lives and in
Flanders word for word it's we know not
where that he
lives tell me what you think in the
Netherlands word for word tell me what
you think and in
Flanders word for word tell me what that
you think vocabulary one of the biggest
differences between Dutch Dutch and
Flemish is the significant amount of
different vocabulary and in many cases
different word preference while the
Dutch of either nation is generally
mutually intelligible with the other
these differences in vocabulary might
result in some temporary confusion or at
least sound little funny to speakers
from the other country the most
dangerous case might be this word in the
Netherlands the word poen means to
defecate in other words to poop pooper
in Flanders it often means to have
sex um yeah some words for members of
the family are different in the
Netherlands if you're an adult speaking
and you want to say my father and my
mother you say my father and my mother
in Flanders you might say say Papa and
Mama in the Netherlands this sounds like
something a child would say then there's
the word for Uncle in the Netherlands
it's om in Flanders
it's the word for brother-in-law in the
Netherlands and in
Flanders then there's the question word
meaning why in the Netherlands
it's while in Flanders you'll likely
hear which literally means for what the
words for some foods are different for
example in the Netherlands the word for
ham is H in Flanders it's HP in the
Netherlands the word for French fries or
chips is B in Flanders it's
FR in the Netherlands the word meaning
to walk is L in Flanders the word l
means to run the word for run in the
Netherlands is r and to run for sport is
Art From what I understand this word
sounds pretty weird to Flemish speakers
so if l means to run in Flemish then how
do they say to walk well they would
likely use the word St another word for
walk as in to step in the Netherlands
Sten is often used with the meaning of
to go out as in to go out drinking or
partying speaking of partying in the
Netherlands the word for a party is
faced or for a smaller Gathering the
diminutive form fascia in Flanders a
common word for party is
f in the Netherlands the adjective
meaning clean is in
this word usually means beautiful to say
beautiful in the Netherlands you
say so if this word means beautiful and
Flemish then what's the word for clean
it's normally proper which you could say
is more like tidy hopefully you keep
your room clean like I do well at least
I clean it right before filming a clean
room in
Netherlands in
Flanders there's a different verb
meaning to clean too in the Netherlands
it's
literally to make clean the typical
Flemish word would
be if your room is clean and tidy then
that puts you in the right head space to
study in the Netherlands the usual verb
meaning to study
is in Flanders it's
blocker
Ro
scroll in Netherlands a cup is normally
called a cup or in Flanders it's
normally called a D in the Netherlands
this word would mean bag one type of bag
you probably have around the house is a
suitcase like I've got this one right
here this big
one in the Netherlands the usual word
for suitcase is goer in Flanders the
usual word is valis this comes from the
French word valiz because French is also
an official language of Belgium and is
the native language of almost 40% of its
population not to mention a second
language of many Flemish speakers
Flemish has many more French lone words
than the Dutch spoken in the Netherlands
does some of these words are nouns like
the word for bicycle in Flanders it's
while in the Netherlands it's fit the
word for heating in Flanders
it's while in the Netherlands it's fing
the word for floor in Flanders it's it
while in the Netherlands it's fa deeping
the word for trailer in Flanders
it's while in the Netherlands
it's the word for newspaper in Flanders
it's Flemish has some other French words
that are greetings and other
interjections mer meaning thank you
instead
of which means go in French this can be
used in a few different contexts like
when you're trying to recall something
that's slipped your mind or when
something's hard to believe like get out
of here or come on in
English which means hold in French this
is used when you need to to interject
that you're wondering about something
like in English I might say hold on or
wait as in wait aren't you supposed to
be at school
today vaa vaa like there or all right or
voila indicating that something's
complete which is something you can say
to bring an issue to a conclusion like
all right it's settled or just all right
there are also some differences in
expressions in the Netherlands and
Flanders some differences are slight for
example there's an expression meaning
surely or definitely in the Netherlands
it's fost and zaker literally fixed and
certain in Flanders it's
typically certain and fixed but in
colloquial speech in both countries it's
commonly just Zer or for extra certainty
Zer some differences are a little more
significant in the Netherlands the
expression meaning I love you
is literally I hold of you or I hold you
in Flanders you're more likely to hear
excuse
word for word it's I see you gladly in
the Netherlands this is interpreted
literally as I like to see you so we've
looked at some of the differences
between Dutch Dutch and the tental of
Flanders but what about Flemish dialects
well the person speaking Flemish in this
video is from a village in the eastern
part of the province of Flemish brabant
let's see some examples from his dialect
to illustrate how the local dialects are
different from standard Dutch and from
tental but keep in mind that this is
just one dialect of many let's look at a
sentence meaning I would have loved to
see you one last time first in the
Netherlands and more broadly in standard
Dutch it would
be word for word it's I had you gladly
yet a last time seen here's the
dialectal
example word for word it translates
exactly the same but you can see that
there are some differences the personal
pronoun meaning I is rather than I the
verb meaning had is ha rather than hot
the object pronoun meaning U is rather
than y these two pronouns are similar to
those in some limburgish dialects since
the speaker's Hometown is in a part of
Flemish brabant that's not too far from
the province of limberg the word for yet
is different this one comes from French
and has more of a contrastive meaning
like however also notice the different
word order next notice the word meaning
gladly or with pleasure is different
next notice the different indefinite
article in the dialectal example this is
the same masculine singular and definite
article that we saw in tental and we can
see that these two words are cognates of
the standard ones but are pronounced and
spelled a little differently remember
that there are lots of dialects in the
Netherlands too so comparing a Flemish
dialect to standard Dutch as it's spoken
in the Netherlands isn't that meaningful
that's why I've spent most of the video
focusing on tental since it's a semi-
standard way of speaking that crosses
Regional and dialectal boundaries in the
way that standard Dutch does in the
Netherlands so here's an equivalent of
the sentence in tental for
comparison you can see that the tental
example is closer to standard Dutch than
the dialectal example but still has a
few differences like the shortened form
of the pronoun meaning I C rather than I
and here we see again that the pronoun
is used even though the sentence is
obviously said to someone the speaker
knows well
remember that in tental this is an
informal and familiar pronoun while in
standard Dutch and in the Netherlands
it's very formal then there's the word
for yet or however this word has a more
contrastive meaning than the standard
word similar to the word used in dialect
then there's the different masculine
indefinite article
again so you've seen that there are some
differences between the way the Dutch
language is spoken in the Netherlands
and in Flanders enough of a difference
to create a little bit of confusion or
Amusement for speakers from the other
country but at the end of the day the
people in both countries speak Dutch and
in both countries they use both standard
Dutch and dialects the main distinction
is that Flemish people use tental the
semi-standard informal way of speaking
that isn't quite dialect and isn't quite
standard in the Netherlands too dialects
are fading more and more with each
generation but they're being replaced
not by an in between language but more
by the standard language at least that's
how it looks to me as an outsider if
you're a native speaker and you disagree
let me know in the comments down below
if you're a native speaker of Dutch from
either the Netherlands or Belgium do you
have any trouble communicating with
people from the other country are there
moments of confusion and to other people
what's your impression of the
differences between Dutch Dutch and
Flemish Dutch do they seem like a big
deal and once again it's time to give a
big shout out to all of the Lang Focus
patreon supporters the top tier patreon
supporters are the ones whose names you
see right here on the screen so let's
give them a big round of applause your
support on patreon helps make content
like this possible you can help support
this channel too at patreon.com/lenguin